no fear just fun
that's how sky brown skates but having
fallen
twice in the final she had just one last
chance to grab a medal
13 years and 28 days old the youngest
ever team gb medalist
is also the smiliest hey guys
i'm so happy to have this medal i'm so
grateful thank you guys for all the
support
she grew up in japan lives in california
but her british dad stew
is the reason she's in the gb vest
she took bronze behind two japanese
skaters a 19 year old gold medal winner
and a 12 year old who won silver the
combined age of the three medalists on
that podium was 44
and that's exactly why the games have
introduced these new sports to find new
audiences
and new olympic heroes sport climbing
with human spiders is addictive bmx
freestyle was spectacular
but you can't ignore sailing where team
gb have cleaned up
hannah mills has won gold just like she
did in rio
this time with ailee mcintyre whose dad
mike won gold in seoul in 1988
for as long as i can remember i've
looked at my dad's gold medal
hung on the wall as all i've ever wanted
is all i've ever dreamed of
and i don't think i ever truly believed
it would actually happen so
for this day to come and for it to be my
first olympics that's such
an unreal thing hannah mills is now
great britain's most successful female
sailor
ever right at the point when skye brown
is just getting started
we bought a sky this morning
yeah what an absolute superstar to get
to get the bronze what an absolute
legend
uh is properly properly caught
and that's why in the skate parks of
tokyo sky brown
is one of the ones they just want to
follow
up her tricks are incredible
but so too is her use of social media
and that's why the olympics matters
amongst all the things it leaves behind
are the people ready to line up next
tom parmenter sky news tokyo